hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and black clover
just completely flipped the script on us
yet again just when we thought that the
black bulls had finally saved yami the
strongest devil lucifer emerges with a
gigantic devil megazord and suddenly
everything looks really bad for our
heroes yet again we need to talk about
this craziness so let's get into it if
you guys enjoy our blacklord content and
you want to see more you know what to do
just leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it helps with
the youtube algorithm and if you're new
to the channel or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
who make videos like this one possible i
will talk more about patreon at the end
of the video but until then please be
advised that this video will contain
black clover manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned the previous chapter ended on a
hopeful and heartwarming note as the
black bulls finally reunited with their
captain yami or at least that's what i
would be saying if not for the very last
panel which revealed that the second
cliff off gate was already opening the
black bulls arrived too late to stop it
the new chapter takes us briefly to the
outside of the palace where my girl
merolona is still crushing some giant
ancient demon hide it's been a long time
since we actually checked in with mario
leona but i just kind of assumed that
she was still kicking ass and i assumed
correctly thanks to the hellfire
incarnate spell that she is using the
more she fights the more her firepower
increases and so eventually her attacks
become so powerful that she straight up
incinerates the ancient demon's gigantic
body the spade kingdom citizens outside
the palace are shocked by the sheer
extent of merolona's power and they
can't believe that a single clover
kingdom magic knight can take out an
ancient demon by themselves as mera
leona prepares to clean up the rest of
the devils who had poured out from the
first cliff of gate the chapter takes us
back inside the palace and man before we
continue can we all just take a moment
to appreciate how badass mero leona is
can i please get a hashtag hottest waifu
down in the comments back on the inside
someone is finally actually mentioning
william remember that guy captain of the
golden dawn yeah he's also there with
yami and he is finally being
acknowledged as language and poetry call
out his name although to be fair those
brief cries of william are quickly
drowned out by the black bulls screaming
yami yet again which not gonna lie is
kind of hilarious meanwhile morris seems
like he really is out for the count
which is pretty embarrassing to be
honest lucifer is still talking through
that mouth on morris's forehead but
morris himself seems to be completely
unconscious i really don't know how to
feel about that since morris has been
doing all this plotting and all of these
experiments for such a long time he also
has a very interesting magic attribute
reconstruction magic or modification
magic depending on the translation he is
also a devil host for lucifer and yet he
was basically one-shotted by henry and
gordon that is extremely anti-climactic
as far as morris is concerned but to be
fair we definitely don't have a shortage
of villains at the moment not with all
those overpowered devils coming up from
the underworld and speaking of the
underworld that second gate has in fact
opened and hundreds if not thousands of
devils are rushing into the human world
as i said before the wholesome reunion
with yami did not last very long and
apparently the gate has opened even
faster than it would have normally
because lucifer squeezed the life out of
morris the gate's accelerant in order to
do it i mean i knew in the end lucifer
was just using morris like he had been
using dante but i didn't think that he
would turn on morris so quickly but it
is what it is i guess no one said that
making deals with the devil are a good
idea lucifer then takes control of all
of those devils who had just poured into
the human world and kind of stacks them
together in a huge pile on top of each
other to create some sort of grotesque
devil megazord oh and he also grabs yami
and william in the process and
incorporates them into the megazord so
that way the black bulls can't free them
and close the cliff off soon the entire
spade kingdom palace is overwhelmed by
the massive devil megazord lucifer
explains that devils who rank lower than
him can be possessed by him and so
thanks to the second gate opening he has
now created an absolutely gigantic devil
monster that puts even the ancient demon
to shame but as scary as this giant
devil monstrosity is the black bulls are
not giving up we see all of them using
their various spells in a coordinated
effort
the black bulls are doing what they do
best top tier teamwork they are not
intimidated by the fact that lucifer is
said to be the strongest devil and the
chapter ends with the black bulls hq
mecca punching the giant demon monster
in the face the final page declares that
this is the beginning of the fierce
battle between the devil megazord and
the black bulls megazord wait when did
this become power rangers anyway this
was absolutely crazy and we seem to have
just gotten the answer to a major
question that we've been asking
ourselves for the past few weeks we were
all surprised when we learned that
lucifer was apparently going to manifest
once the second gate opens because we
all assume that lucifer was down on the
lowest floor of the underworld not on
the second floor so far it seems that he
is not yet manifesting in his true body
he is currently managing to manifest
through the second gate by controlling
all of those lower devils so this means
that the devil megazord will likely be
very powerful but it still won't be
nearly as powerful as lucifer once he is
able to actually enter this world in his
true body that said we still have a lot
of unanswered questions when will
lucifer's true body actually make an
appearance is this going to happen
sometime soon or are we going to have to
wait for all of those different gates to
open and speaking of the gates when will
the next one open is lucifer going to
speed up the process or are we gonna be
waiting a long time for all of these
gates to actually open also what is
going on with yami and william they were
so close to being rescued and now
they've been abducted again this time by
the devil megazord are we going to see
yami and william finally liberated and
actually taking part in this fight
anytime soon or is tabitha just going to
continue teasing us with the potential
return of yami and dark magic and i
guess also william because why not let's
pretend like we care don't forget to
leave your feedback down in the comments
below i always love hearing from you if
you guys enjoyed this video and you want
to see more black lover content right
here on the channel leave a quick like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps a lot and if you're new to
anime uproar or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting the bell and then
selecting that option that says all if
you don't do that you're still gonna
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror i want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime opera
patrons who make videos like this one
possible special thank you to alpha
sigma this man is an absolute mad lad
and a disciple of lord twego himself and
i can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ingrata algital
pate heffa the red haired fox hinokami
and water the toasted chi corey mcgowan
the spike dylan isidor spidey life tinel
tungsten tarkis baked buddhist monkey d
quilly cody hebert and jeremy cummings
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel crews very
gucci alicia octor bonnie parks joy and
garcia fat boy games kaido might be a
duck jessica rabbit and jeremy phillips
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you